Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now panicking about
the increasingly likely scenario in which his
tax returns leak. He spent the overnight on his
platform truth, social censure. Call it whatever
you want. Complaining and telling lies. Let's
back up just a little bit. There's two things
going on simultaneously. Later today, the
January six committee is expected to announce
which criminal referrals are they sending to the
Department of Justice? Trump may be on that list.
We don't yet know. That's number one. Separately,
the House Ways and Means Committee has finally
obtained Donald Trump's tax returns. Trump spent
years trying to keep them secret. For a guy with
nothing to hide, I haven't seen so much money
spent trying to keep those tax returns secret.
Trump is now worried that the tax returns are
going to leak, and he clearly is worried. But I
believe because he thinks that the subject, the
content of those tax returns would be bad for him.
So he goes on Trump Central. Last night,
ten, 11, midnight, and he starts, quote,
The highly partizan UN Select Committee is
illegally leaking confidential info to anyone that
will listen. Adam Schiff The Schiff is all over
TV talking about Capital C criminal referrals,
just like he was on the Russia Russia Russia hoax,
which turned out to be the con of the century. How
much longer are Republicans and American patriots
in general going to allow this to happen? These
are the Capital C criminals who spied on my
campaign, cheated on the Capitol election,
lied to FISA court and Congress. They are
sick. TRUMP Then when Trump starts these rants,
it's often like, okay, what's this? What's
this about? What triggered this? His next
post exposes what this is all about. Trump says,
quote, You can't learn much from tax returns,
but it is illegal to release them if they are not
yours. Trump worried about his tax returns being
released. It's also not true that you can't
learn much from tax returns. Tax experts have
said you might be able to glean from tax returns
that Trump's not as wealthy as he claims to be,
that he has debts to shady figures that might have
him compromised, that he is engaged in tax fraud
and a number of other things. Trump continuing,
quote, All of the so-called experts who think that
they know so much about my very successful private
company actually know almost nothing. It is a
great company with lots of cash and some of the
greatest assets anywhere in the capital w world
and very little debt. Also strong on deductions
and depreciation. You will be seeing these numbers
soon. Where have we heard that report before?
From before, but not all from my tax returns,
which show relatively little. Everyone will be
impressed, but the fake news media will not be
happy. So against their narrative. Is anybody
still falling for the. We're going to release
the documents very soon. I mean, that's been
going on for almost eight years at this point.
Trump Continuing The real criminals are the
people who are destroying our once great
capitalist country and Trump closing it off.
Election interference by the FBI and Twitter
was massive and determinative. How sad. Of course
that's not true. But when in doubt, go back to,
I guess, what's been working for you, which is
claim you really won. More than two years ago.
Oh, boy. If the tax returns leak, this guy is
going to go cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. And I look
forward to it. I would never encourage anyone to
commit a crime or leak anything. But if the tax
returns leak, it's going to be quite a scene.
Folks, this Friday, we are doing something we
have never done before. Friday, December 23rd.
Yes, we're doing a membership special. It's the
last membership special of the year. But here's
the incredible thing we are doing. Your first
month's payment of this discounted membership will
be donated by us to a charity that they don't run
it through this huge, complex process where at
the end of the day, $0.45 on the dollar get to
the people we're trying to help. We are going
to be donating the first months of everybody's
memberships this Friday when you use a special
coupon code to a charity that sends cash to
people who need it. And we're talking to people
who really need it, people living on a dollar a
day to like $2 a day. Okay. In addition, the
money is going to be doubled now. I can't say
exactly through which charity, because if I did,
it creates a marketing situation where a contract
is just complicated. So what we've been told to
do is, David, just promote it this way. And then
on Friday, you can announce what you're doing
with the money once you already have it. Okay,
so it's for legal reasons. We're doing it that
way. How do you get notified about all of this?
This is unbelievable. You will get a membership
at a discount and that discounted payment will go
to people who need it and be doubled. We've never
done something like this before. I want it to be
really successful. Get on my mailing list at David
Pakman dot com top right of the website. You'll
see a place you can type in your email. You do
need to know your email address for that to work.
Friday morning, you'll get an email telling you,
here's the coupon code, every payment is going
to be donated and it will be doubled. It will be
matched dollar for dollar up to the first $15,000,
which I think is going to be more than enough
for for our purposes. I'll talk more about it.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more from the news of the weekend.